hey if you want to get some epic anime
merch that you're not gonna find
anywhere else check out our online store
anime out Broadcom we have esken or
praise the Sun Mele Otis feel the wrath
bond love the pain more esken or more
Mele Otis and other things too so check
us out link in the description what is
up everybody its Anna Mac here for anime
uproar and today I will be talking about
the massive esken or twist that just
went down in the seven deadly sins story
this twist is definitely a game changer
and depending on how you interpret what
just happened this could be very good
news or very bad news for Eskin or if
you're wondering what exactly I'm
referring to don't worry I will break
down all the latest developments and
their potential consequences right here
for your convenience if you enjoy the
seven deadly sins content on this
channel and you'd like to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell seriously hitting that
Bell and turning on all notifications is
really important now on YouTube it's
just how it works if you don't do that
you will probably miss a lot of our
videos this video and other videos like
it are made possible by our awesome
anime opera patrons I will talk more
about our patreon at the end of the
video but first please be warned that
this video will contain manga spoilers I
will be dealing with the latest
developments in the seven deadly sins
story so manga spoilers are coming
proceed with caution
you have been warned Chapter three to
seven of the seven deadly sins manga is
called the man named eScan or so if you
weren't sure by now whether Danns moment
to shine was already over after one
whole chapter now we know for sure at
the very end of the previous chapter we
saw esken or announced to the demon king
that he had some bad news for him and
the news was that it's high noon the
chapter ended with Hester's
transformation in its initial stages but
in Chapter three two 7s Kannur has
already transformed into the Titan of a
man that he is in his the one-state the
demon king recognizes this power the
power of the one because he had seen it
back when he was monitoring everything
from purgatory
and although he acknowledges that this
is the power that was able to overcome
both Mellie Otis and zelgius on
different occasions the demon king knows
that the ones weakness is that it only
lasts for a single minute because of
this the demon king is not intimidated
by the power of the wand rather he
thinks this power is interesting and he
wants to see for himself what
ESCA nor is truly capable of the other
sins make it clear that even though s
Connor is now in his the one form he is
not alone in this fight they are all
here to help
however s Kannur tells them to stay out
of this as he approaches the demon king
and stands face to face with him
we know how huge the demon Kings current
form is compared to the size of say a
normal human but in his the one form s
kannur is actually slightly taller than
the demon king the two men began a
fierce and absolutely incredible battle
the clash between them is so intense
that even the spectators are being
thrown around by the shock waves and
meliodas is actually forced to protect
Elizabeth and gelda with his body just
so they wouldn't be injured by the
after-effects of the battle now that s
canora's in his the one form again he is
at his most cocky and confident but we
have to take everything he says from now
on with a grain of salt because of all
the information that we have learned
about him in the story so far
for example as he clashes with the demon
king both men are clearly doing a
significant amount of damage to each
other
frankly it seems like a fairly even
match as the two behemoths go
head-to-head and blow-for-blow but as
the demon king gets the upper hand he
mocks a scanner and tells him to behold
the power of the Demon Lord he tells us
Kennard that his own power is in a
different dimension from the power of
his two sons implying that s Kannur has
no hope of defeating him in the same way
that he defeated malleolus and Zell
drous but s Kunal replies by saying that
the pain he feels from the demon Kings
blows is only a puny sensation and that
the demon Kings punches are not hurting
him in the slightest nevertheless we
have to remember what s Kannur said in
previous chapters back before he
regained possession of sunshine he said
that when he had fought meliodas
s Kannur definitely felt immense pain
the pain was so bad that s Kannur
thought that he was going to die
but he carried on because of his
unwavering commitment to do the right
no matter what even if it's at the cost
of his very life so when s Kannur says
that he doesn't feel the demon King's
punches this is not true the demon
King's current power is far greater than
Mele Otis's power back when he had
fought s Kannur so you better believe
that s Connor feels these punches and
that he is suffering under the burden of
unbelievable pain however because he is
so determined to help his friends and to
protect them and everyone else in
Britannia from the demon king s Kannur
is dealing with the pain and he is
pushing forward against all odds s
Connor is sacrificing his own body for
the sake of others and he is using his
superhuman determination to overcome the
terrible pain that he must be feeling
this is also why s Connor told the rest
of the seven deadly sins to stay out of
this it's not because he is 100%
confident that he won't need their help
it is because s Connor wants to protect
his friends from being seriously injured
or even killed by the demon king because
of this s Kannur is going to do his very
best to end this battle now before the
demon king has the opportunity to hurt
his friends or anyone else s can or will
do everything in his power to defeat the
demon king right here and now and to
save everyone in the process but this
also means that s Kannur is going all
out in this battle and that he is
putting his body on the line we know
from his previous conversation with my L
that if he puts too much strain on his
body in this battle s can or may not be
able to take it and he might literally
die but as we saw when a powerless s
Canora put his life on the line to
defend Gil Thunder Hauser and gree amour
F from the Endura spawn s Kenard is
willing to sacrifice his life to protect
others he is willing to give up his life
to save his friends and this means that
S Connor may very well put his life in
serious jeopardy during this battle in
order to try to defeat the demon king
even if the odds are stacked against him
this is very noble of s Kannur it is a
testament to the strength of his
character but it is also very dangerous
while a more cautious character might
put more emphasis on teamwork in order
to protect himself s Kannur is willing
to give it all for this one fight and
this willingness to go all out could end
up costing him everything here's the
important thing to remember
as much as we respect his bravery and
commitment the fact remains that if s
Kannur dies now he can't protect anyone
later if he gives up his life that might
be a noble act but it also means that he
can't do any good for anyone else in the
future including his friends perhaps
teamwork at this point would be a much
wiser and safer strategy for everyone
but s Kannur is nothing if not stubborn
and he continues to go blow-for-blow
with the demon king on his own but even
though both s Kannur and the demon king
are landing blows on each other and even
though these blows have immense force
neither of the two men is backing down
neither of them has been knocked down
and let alone knocked out
dn and the other sins are shocked that
the demon king is withstanding the
incredible attacks that are coming from
s Canora in his the one state and even
though the demon king is definitely
taking damage as bond rightly points out
the big problem is time the demon king
praises s Kannur and gives him his due
since the demon king never thought that
any human could hold his own as an equal
against him but even so even after all
of that the demon king points out that
the time is up an entire minute has
already passed and s Kannur will now be
reverting back to his normal daytime
state even though s Kannur did manage to
do some significant damage to the demon
king he did not manage to knock him down
or knock him out and now it's too late
however as s Kannur is about to lose his
the one state we see the words my friend
now I will finally fulfill my promise in
the next moment instead of shrinking to
his normal daytime form s Kannur size
increases until he is towering over the
demon king even though just a moment ago
they were roughly the same height ESCA
NORs the one form seems to be evolving
into some new even stronger form it's
like the 12.0 or something crazy like
that I don't know what to say about it I
did not see this coming
I was thinking that while s Kannur is in
his regular 2:1 form the other sins
would use teamwork to help him defeat
the demon king I never for a moment
envisioned that s Connor would somehow
unlock a power up beyond the one there
are two potential explanations for this
or
at least two but there could be more
that I am just not seeing the first is
that those words that we saw about
fulfilling my promise are coming from my
Elle if that is the case then I assume
that when my L gave sunshine back to s
kannur he gave him even more power than
he had before
meaning that mile past some of his own
Archangel powers on to s Kannur this is
a logical way to explain an additional
power up for s Canora miles Archangel
powers are allowing s Kannur to stay in
the one beyond one minute and to evolve
beyond the regular the one form into
some sort of the 12.0 or the - I don't
even know what to call it if you've been
following my seven deadly sins videos
for a while then you know how
disappointed I was with my L and his
refusal to personally fight the demon
king out of what seemed like pure
cowardice nevertheless it now seems that
my L might have redeemed himself just a
bit by making Eskin or even stronger
than he used to be and this means that
the new-and-improved s can or the
evolved s Kannur probably has a much
better chance of defeating the demon
king that Miele would have had on his
own which makes Myles decision to sit on
the sidelines at least somewhat more
understandable but that is just one
option the second option is that mile
has nothing to do with this and the
words about keeping a promise were
coming from s Kannur and they were
directed at meli otis in that case it's
esken or saying that he intends to keep
his promise to protect his friends but
he will do it at the expense of his own
body and his own life if s Kannur is
forcing his body to go beyond the one
without any external help from someone
like my l then i am afraid that s Kannur
is probably going to get himself killed
his body has already been exhausted from
his use of sunshine and if he is now
going to push his body beyond the one
then I really fear that the story might
be building up to s canora's actual
death I hope that's not the case we
don't want to lose Big Daddy sunshine
and one of the manliest characters in
anime but I just don't know at this
point now the official translation which
I read on crunchyroll does not have any
text on the final page but one of the
other translations states that this is
going to be continued in the sighs story
called the king sings of loneliness
if this is true what exactly does it
mean is the main story about to take a
detour to explore the backstory of
either Eskin or or the demon king which
one of them is the king who sings of
loneliness is it both of them are we
going to get a side story that reveals
more about s canora's life or maybe more
about the demon King's life including
potentially the true nature of the demon
King's relationship with the supreme
deity I honestly don't know the idea
that this epic primetime clash between
two behemoths warriors would be
continuing in a Side Story is kind of
crazy let me know what you guys think
about this are we going to get some type
of side story that explores the origins
of the demon king or Eskin or or both is
this side story going to be separate
from the main plotline like the vampires
of Edinboro is it going to be a bonus
chapter chapter three 27.5 or something
like that or is the official chapter
three to eight going to cover the side
story please give me your thoughts on
this down in the comments below
personally I am pretty concerned about
Eskin Orr's well-being if option two is
true and Miele had nothing to do with
Hester NORs new powerup if a second or
is pushing himself to the breaking point
to make this powerup happen this could
very well be the end of Eskin or which
would suck a lot but we'll have to wait
and see if you enjoy the seven deadly
sins content on this channel and you'd
like to see more please leave a like to
let me know and if you happen to be new
to anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
feel free to follow me on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar for all the
latest seven deadly sins news and
updates I want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime outpour patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thanks to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress on hell cruise stealers
poet Pablo atropos Wraith and fitty
dalla beat and also an epic thank you to
all of ours the one tear patrons the
ones who stand above all other clans
including Ingrid ah a Lola madam madam
AK and makoto-kun
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron only discord and to show our
gratitude your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]